Paula Deen prepares to return to TV with  Dancing with the Stars I just want to  bring out especially to older women in  the middle part of their life you can  have a lot of obstacles come your way  but we're unexpected and I just I just  want to help women realize that they can  overcome but Ichi how to know can Paula  overcome her most famous guilty pleasure  butter biscuits with the Stars  rehearsals they're pretty grueling have  you cut out any butter from your diet no  I will never cut out butter totally  never ever ever ah moderation you know  moderation is the big word in my life  right now especially when it comes to  price wrecking on that one we agree to  disagree on that subject is it real now  have you tasted her cooking are you  kidding me we the first two weeks we  rehearsed and fall is home next to the  kitchen their lot they want much time  for cooking no but what Paula cooks oh  oh amazing so good